et ce matin des cyclistes amateurs ont
eu le plaisir de précéder les champions
le parcours de la dernière étape de la
grande boucle l'heure et est entièrement
réservé reportage de marie paule rigali
gwenaël rihet images impressionnantes ce
matin dès 8 heures plus de 11000
cyclotouristes attendait le début d'un
rêve 28 km de parcours parisien sur le
tracé de la 20e étape du tour de france
2000 28 km est accessible à tout le
monde ça n'est pas une compétition c'est
une balade alors ils sont là les
cyclistes et des parisiens des
franciliens des français beaucoup
d'étrangers aussi ils sont ils seront
onze mille 12000 et je crois qu'ils
pourront découvrir les merveilleuses
artères de paris et puis se prendre un
peu pour les coureurs du tour de france
l'espace d'une horde merde il n'y aurait
ni nos pas moins de trois quintuple
vainqueur de la grande boucle pour
ouvrir ce cortège on s'y croirait
presque
l'ambiance est bon enfant ici pas de
compétition et porter une réplique d'un
des plus beaux maillots c'est pas rien
ancien avoir le maillot à pois oh non
c'est vraiment le maillot un petit peu
dans la pochette surprise alors
simplement ce que pour un cycliste faut
le gagner un maillot alors c'est quand
même un petit peu l'amusement quoi on
est passé par la cloche et j'espérais le
maillot blanc de meilleur jeune
mais le maillot vert c'est ainsi qu'en
3e et lumière pourrait pas courant du
routeur comme chico perez journaliste
depuis 35 ans sur le tour 7e randonnée a
quelque chose de magique à l'épée le
temps de savourer le repas des vigiles
pour la tour eiffel et profits diem et
l'egypte facebook
cette balade est très décontractée en
famille ou entre amis en vtt bicloo nous
viennent encore vélo de pro s'est
terminée sans incidents peu avant